[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti è molto bello essere
qui con voi se trema un po la voce non
so se sia per l'emozione di condividere
questa giornata con voi o per il freddo
che comincia a farsi sentire
e bello essere qui con voi
quello che vorrei proporvi oggi è un
ragionamento in realtà che sta un po
all'atto della scienza sapete io fin da
quando ero alto così mi sono occupato di
animali selvatici e di natura
oggi proprio per questo motivo
preferirei condividere con voi un
ragionamento che sta i lati della
scienza che si sviluppa anche con fido
con un po di follia e si conclude
contaminato dall'emotività e dalle
emozioni nei confronti della natura
l'idea è nata alcuni mesi fa quando a
cena con degli amici tra una risata e
l'altra mi sono sentito chiedere eva ma
uno più uno quanto fa e io di getto
praticamente senza pensarci ha risposto
ed è quasi sempre due perché di fatto
nel sistema decimale che quello basato
sull'evidenza che la maggior parte degli
uomini hanno a disposizione dieci dita
per contare uno più uno da sempre due è
un conto semplice inequivocabile però
tutto sommato è strano perché per gli
ingegneri uno più uno da sempre due per
gli architetti uno più uno spesso da da
circa 2 sto scherzando un pochino
ovviamente ma per gli zoologi uno più
uno da quasi sempre 2
ma per quale motivo perché
è chiaro che la mia è una forzatura
nella forzatura di un racconto che parte
da una cena realmente accaduta ma che
poi dovrebbe svilupparsi secondo
regionalmente un pochino più sobrio e
anche di carattere scientifico
però di fatto per chi si occupa di di
scienze naturali uno più uno da quasi
sempre due perché ci si aspetta il
l'errore della natura
però attenzione perché gli ecosistemi
che stiamo condividendo sono così
perfetti se vogliamo
che l'errore della natura deve essere
considerato come una parte integrante ed
essenziale per il mantenimento degli
equilibri ecosistemici
quindi probabilmente non possiamo
nemmeno parlare in senso proprio di di
errori dobbiamo parlare di qualche cosa
di diverso dobbiamo parlare di una
straordinaria confusione creativa da
parte della natura
è una straordinaria confusione creativa
che nasce in realtà già dalla meiosi che
quel meraviglioso e per certi versi
magico momento nel quale i geni si
ricombinano tra di loro
apparentemente senza logica alcuna per
dare origine a gameti maschili e
femminili fino a questo momento ci
accorgiamo che la vita si avvale
dell'errore per cercare nuove strade
utili per affrontare un futuro che è in
costante evoluzione
il presente si avvale del passato e
cerca di programmare di preparare il
futuro
di temi anche voi quale modo migliore
c'è di programmare il futuro se non
quello di provare strade differenti e
poi cercare di premiare quelle che sono
più adeguate all'evolversi costante dei
tempi
da te che tutto sommato darvin nel 1859
lo aveva ben descritto questo meccanismo
meraviglioso che è basato su tentativi
di evoluzione costanti che hanno portato
all'affermarsi di forme di vita
differenti sul nostro pianeta
ancora una volta forse non dovevano
nemmeno parlare di tentativi ma di
qualcosa di diverso dovremo parlare in
una costante creazione di diversità da
parte della natura
e filosofeggiando forse dovremmo anche
noi ricordarci che nella diversità che
si cresce e che si possono trovare nuove
soluzioni
quella diversità che a volte ci fa paura
anche nella quotidianità ma che rimane
un valore assoluto
in natura tra l'altro il concetto di
diversità si sovrappone quasi
completamente al concetto di
biodiversità la complessità delle forme
di vita che sono presenti sul pianeta e
quindi in ultima analisi si sovrappone
anche al concetto di una natura che
rimane sana ed integra e credetemi è
proprio per questo che in natura
uno più uno deve dare quasi sempre due
perché la natura è riuscita a prevedere
la possibilità che dagli errori si crei
diversità e che quindi dagli errori si
riesca a rinnovare la vita
in sistemi creati dall'uomo non
funzionano in questo modo i sistemi che
creiamo noi cercano di evitare l'errore
o tutt'al più cercano di correggerlo
alla fine
la natura no
la natura funziona in un modo
assolutamente differente cerca di far
arrivare la giusta quantità gli errori
per poi gestirli in modo da vendo vasi
svecchiarsi in ultima analisi per
riuscire ad evolversi
voi direte che parolone che discorsi
forse anche un po complicati ai limiti
della scienza ma complicati no la
situazione più semplice di quello che
non si possa pensare prendiamo il collo
delle giraffe che è il frutto di una
selezione naturale da arzignano le
giraffe ancestrali avevano il collo
sicuramente molto più più corto poi
alcuni individui che potremmo chiamare
anomali diversi forse hanno iniziato a
cibarsi delle foglie poste un pochino
più in alto e facendo questo sono
riusciti ad alimentarsi meglio a
sopravvivere ha quindi a mandare i loro
geni nel nel futuro ed evolvere le forme
attuali che conosciamo
ma non c'è bisogno evidentemente di di
andare verso i meravigliosi animali
africani per comprendere che anche sulle
nostre montagne nella storia
dell'evoluzione in casi rari uno più uno
non ha dato due ci sono per esempio
delle capre selvatiche
che noi conosciamo come stambecchi che
sono arrivati sulle nostre montagne
circa 150 200 mila anni fa quando
l'europa era una unica distesa di
ghiaccio e di neve
successivamente
quando il pianeta si è andato a
riscaldare gli stambecchi sono rimasti
confinati solo sulle montagne più
elevate laddove le condizioni climatiche
erano probabilmente più idonea al
passato più simili a quelle che erano
nel nel passato
ebbene in questo viaggio evolutivo lo
stambecco ha rinunciato a una delle due
mute annuali del mantello e ancora oggi
in primi in autunno all'approssimarsi
del freddo antiche perdere la pelliccia
estiva semplicemente fa spuntare sopra
di essa dei nuovi teli più lunghi più
folti un pochettino se ci pensiamo
eccome come mettersi un maglione di lana
all'inizio dell'inverno senza toglierci
la felpa che ci ha accompagnato alla
fine dell'estate almeno in questo caso
due è meglio di uno per difendersi dal
freddo è una cosa certa
sempre lo stambecco che è un animale
particolarmente adattato a vivere in
montagna ea vivere anche sulla roccia
hai voluto una zampa molto particolare
una zampa costituita da due unghioni
morbidi di sostanza
simile alla gomma che si usa sotto le
scarpette di moderni scalatori tutto
sommato e poi unghioni sono anche
indipendenti nel movimento l'uno
rispetto rispetto all'altro tanto da far
sì che quando cammina sulle rocce questo
animale addirittura non appoggi sul
terreno solo con 4 punti corrispondente
i quattro arti ma addirittura con 8
punti corrispondenti agli 8 milioni
4x2 è uguale 8 in questo caso la
matematica evidentemente certa però ci
sono anche altri animali straordinari
sulle nostre montagne che hanno evoluto
discreti trucchi per riuscire a
difendersi dal freddo e dalle intemperie
dell'inverno
prendiamo ad esempio i tetraonidi che
sono dei galliformi quindi degli animali
non molto dissimili dalle nostre cave
galline e bene
it e trony di hanno voluto una
i polacchi de che è una più mettina che
sta sotto quella che potremmo chiamare
la piuma principale che difende questi
animali dal freddo perché nell'insieme
va a costituire una sorta di sottomaglia
capace appunto di difenderli dalle dalle
intemperie
però non è finita perché questi animali
eccezionali hanno anche
delle piccole più metti nei che stanno
alla base che stanno sul capo e che che
ricoprono le narici di questi di questi
animali hanno anche del di tarsi piumati
stile stile moon boot potremmo dire con
delle piume che assomigliano molto a dei
teli sottili e che quindi aiutano a
termoregolare questo animale
però se osserviamo una stella alpina ci
rendiamo conto che anche le stelle
alpine hanno sui petali una sottile
peluria e sotto certi punti di vista la
cosa è straordinaria se ci pensate
perché forme di vita così differenti le
stelle alpine e tetraonidi
hanno mostrato una convergenza evolutiva
cioè hanno affrontato lo stesso problema
in questo caso il freddo invernale
utilizzando soluzioni tecniche e tutto
sommato simili una peluria che ricopre
che ricopre il loro corpo ci sono altri
esempi sulle alpi di convergenza
evolutiva pensate ai grandi padiglioni
auricolari del capriolo che poi sono
molto simili ai padiglioni auricolari
delle delle elettriche ben conosciamo e
che ci confermano che nella storia
dell'evoluzione di queste specie sono
stati premiati gli animali più capaci di
ascoltare i rumori del bosco quelli che
riuscivano a comprendere la prossima se
l'avvicinarsi di un predatore che hanno
avuto la possibilità di riprodursi e di
portare poi alle linee che conosciamo
attualmente con con queste grandi
orecchie allo stesso tempo però i
predatori si sono dovuti adeguare alla
nuova situazione e quindi sono diventati
più silenziosi hanno evoluto dei trucchi
olfattivi per essere più efficienti ed
efficaci durante la caccia
in questo caso si parla di co evoluzione
specie animali differenti che si
evolvono spingendosi l'un l'altro a
trovare delle modifiche utili per
affrontare il futuro però credetemi
all'inizio della storia c'è sempre un
anomalia rispetto alle forme che sono
state viste precedentemente sul pianeta
una differenza che si moltiplica viene
premiata si tramanda e poi rimane
fissata in nove specie che sono più
adeguate al contesto nel quale sono
chiamate a vivere i pipistrelli hanno
addirittura imparato a volare nel buio
assoluto
hanno voluto un sonar che permette loro
di catturare degli insetti laddove per
tutti gli altri mammiferi terrestri non
è possibile farlo
una soluzione tecnica che ha permesso
loro di conquistare una nicchia
ecologica come l'aria che è molto
importante per degli insettivori una
soluzione tecnica che è stata
scopiazzata dall'uomo che incuriosito
dalle capacità straordinarie di questi
animali li ha studiati a fondo fino a
rubargli segreto del sonar che di fatto
ha spostato gli equilibri della seconda
guerra mondiale perché ha permesso alle
navi degli alleati di smascherare la
presenza dei sommergibili tedeschi che
fino a poco tempo prima erano del tutto
invisibili invisibili come degli insetti
che volano nel buio
anche la nostra specie devo dire è
evoluto discreti trucchi per riusciva ad
essere così di successo sul pianeta
abbiamo denunciato la pelliccia caso
unico tra l'altro tra i mammiferi
a parte i capelli perché sappiamo che
circa il 40 per cento della dispersione
del calore avviene proprio dal capo
abbiamo sviluppato una in cielo di
discrete dimensioni
qualcuno di voi penserà a chi più chi
meno e non posso dargli torto e poi
abbiamo sviluppato un invenzione
eccezionale il pollice opponibile che
sta alla base di moltissime delle nostre
capacità
ma che cosa sto cercando di raccontarvi
e oggi che la maggior parte delle specie
animali sono sostanzialmente uno scrigno
di informazioni che si sono accumulate
nel tempo
l'insieme di queste informazioni di
queste meravigliose forme
costituisce la biodiversità
e rappresenta il nostro futuro
quindi
quindi a parte l'intelligenza
sconvolgente della natura che è riuscita
a inventare tutto prima di noi quello
che rimane è che anche noi siamo natura
anche l'uomo e natura e se questa
affermazione vero è vera allora quando
facciamo una passeggiata troviamo anche
noi a guardare con nuovi occhi proviamo
a sentirci come una parte integrante
dell'ecosistema che ci circonda una
parte in evoluzione una parte in viaggio
insieme a tante altre specie animali e
vegetali che hanno trovato delle
soluzioni straordinarie per rimanere
insieme a noi
se riusciamo a maturare un atteggiamento
di questo tipo ma che potremmo definire
un atteggiamento di scoperta allora
riusciamo ad accentuare anche la nostra
sensibilità nei confronti delle cose
belle che la natura ci dona
e se facciamo questo
riusciamo sicuramente a godere di più di
quello che abbiamo intorno a noi è un po
come conoscere la storia di una scultura
di un di un palazzo di una pittura
custodite in una pinacoteca la
conoscenza riconosce storia e
delicatezza si porta ad osservare con
occhi nuovi e si porta anche ad un
maggior rispetto delle cose che stiamo
osservando
e quindi se poi riusciamo a sviluppare
un senso estetico nei confronti delle
forme della natura siamo subito più
ricchi perché abbiamo nella mente negli
occhi una fonte di gioia la eccezionale
che è capace di accompagnarci in questo
nostro strano viaggio il mio auspicio è
che da oggi voi non riuscite più a
vedere
un animale o una pianta con gli occhi
che avete avuto fino ad oggi
il mio messaggio conclusivo è che la
natura è lo spettacolo più incredibile
del mondo
non è gratis però e qui e ci circonda
con tanto amore
grazie
[Applauso]